all right listen I know people in my
audience some people in my audience are
going to get mad at me
because there are people in my audience
who love Marianne Williamson
and they say Marianne is willing to make
criticisms of the status quo that many
candidates won't make but I'm sorry guys
I can't take the new age self-help gurus
seriously
and I am going to tell you what I think
and I know some of you will be mad and
you're going to email me and that's okay
it's great that Marianne Williamson is
willing to say things like both parties
are widely controlled by corporations
that's great she says it it's not the
type of thing you hear Joe Biden say but
that notwithstanding I am not super
excited about Marianne Williamson
announcing that she will be challenging
President Joe Biden for the 2024
Democratic nomination
I'm just not excited I don't believe
that she is someone who could seriously
do the job and it is very difficult for
me to take her seriously based on her
basically being a version of Deepak
Chopra
that's that's the way I now perfectly
nice individual I've had her on the
program
I I love her whole thing about we need
more love and all that I love all of it
but this is not something that I'm going
to get excited about and uh uh I'll I'll
talk a little bit about it and I know
there are people in my audience who like
this the fact that Marianne Williamson
makes criticisms that many Democrats
aren't willing to make doesn't to me
mean that she should be president
there's lots of people that make
criticisms that I find to be real good
criticisms that I wouldn't go and say
well make them president she was able to
gain a big Reddit and Twitter following
she capitalized on some meme culture
she's interesting like I get it she
holds some reasonable left-wing views
that I perfectly well agree with she's
for Medicare for all I think she's for
DACA granting some kind of permanent
status for those who were brought to the
U.S undocumented before they were adults
I think she's for the green New Deal she
seems very serious about climate change
that's all great
is there any evidence that she can or
would actually be able to do anything
about it but more importantly I just
can't take people seriously when they
have a history of touting all sorts of
woo-woo pseudoscience including sort of
flirting with anti-vax stuff although
she's kind of backed off of it a little
when some of the repercussions weren't
so good she's promoted this Prosperity
Gospel stuff that you often hear from
the Christian preachers you can look at
her 2012 book for examples of that she
sounds like Deepak Chopra half the time
with these unintelligible quotes that
are sort of like meant to sound profound
but they don't really mean anything just
one example is when she said everyone
feels on some level like an alien in
this world because we are we come from
another Realm Of Consciousness and long
for home
wow but that just as easily could be a
Deepak Chopra quote another example Yin
is feminine Earth Yang is masculine Sky
when God is seen as he the soul is seen
as she just archetypes Spirit
impregnates soul
it's just not for me it's not for me one
other one God is Big swine flu is small
see every cell of your body filled with
Divine Light pour God's love on our
immune systems truth protects
it's just not for me guys Okay so
totally fine that she's running good for
her I have no problem with her running
she should run if she wants to it's just
not for me and hopefully people in my
audience understand that now one
argument that I saw three people emailed
me about this and all three said the
same thing Marianne Williamson is going
to push Biden to the left
I don't see how and what I mean by that
is if Biden runs for re-election there's
not going to be like a real primary and
Marianne Williamson isn't going to get
on the debate stage with Joe Biden now
you could say well she should she should
be fine
she's not going to push Biden left
because if Biden runs she's not going to
get on the debate stage no one will pay
attention
and I do think it's also important to
mention that if she somehow managed to
become the nominee and somehow managed
to become president
she would get nothing done she would
literally get nothing done she doesn't
know how to get bills passed she has no
idea about any of that stuff and I have
no confidence if the completely
impossible were to happen if someone
paid attention and she won the
nomination and she became president I
don't think she would be able to get
anything done I don't believe that it is
serious I think it's perfectly fine and
interesting I completely support her
right to run but it is not for me email
me insults I'm ready folks we'll have
all of today's Clips on our Instagram
which you can find by searching
Instagram for David packman show
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping